the rules of engagement have changed
if you can't identify the target
you are the target
the year is 2019 cia operative alex is
running a covert operation in vedance
russia to investigate a shipment of
dangerous chemicals that are headed for
uzdan
alex and his team are soon ambushed by
an unidentified group of terrorists
killing several of the marines and
escaping with the chemical agent
alex's cia handler kate laswell requests
the assistance of sas captain john price
in recovering the chemicals and
de-escalating the situation with russia
24 hours later in london ses sergeant
kyle garrick and his team are following
a group of suspected terrorists
while attempting to stop the van it
suddenly takes off eventually exploding
in the piccadilly circus
it was at that moment that a number of
armed men appeared opening fire on
civilians
garrick his team and the london police
try to stop them
but dozens of civilians are killed
with the last minute arrival of price
the terrorists are killed and the
situation is contained
garrett tells price that they had intel
on the attack earlier but would prevent
it from acting
price recruits garrick for his team
meanwhile in uzdan a terrorist group
alcatala claims responsibility for the
attack
alex is sent to uzdaan to meet up with
price's contact
rebel leader farah karim
she agrees to help in tracking down the
chemicals in exchange for his aid and
overthrowing the russian forces
when farah was seven years old russian
forces led by barkov were invading uzdan
farrah and her mother were buried by the
rebel from a russian artillery strike
although her mother was killed farah
managed to survive
the russian soldiers began advancing on
her position
she was grabbed by her father who rushed
her to their home to find her brother
hadir
suddenly a soldier burst into the house
he fires his weapon at their father
ferrara sneaks through the house and
finds something to defend herself
she then attacks the russian soldier and
as he begins to fight back
her dear too starts attacking him with
another makeshift weapon
they managed to bring him down
after saying goodbye to their dying
father the two of them sneak out of
their home in search of a vehicle they
can escape him
unfortunately upon entering a truck they
are then immediately captured by roman
barkov the russian general responsible
for invading their homeland
they would be held captive for the next
10 years
as prisoners of war farah and hadir were
barely fed or given water and were
consistently tortured for information on
the identity of someone called commander
kareem
while imprisoned she was given a key by
hadir and at that same moment barkov
arrived
he ordered his men to take a deer to a
warehouse
while he dealt with farah
while interrogating her some more he is
interrupted by an explosion from outside
the compound
before he leaves to investigate barkov
orders his men to take all the prisoners
to the warehouse and kill them
farrah then escapes herself after
killing a few guards she makes it to the
main cell block and is greeted by her
sisters who show her what the key is for
a weapon cabinet
they grabbed some weapons and proceeded
to fight their way out of the prison
complex towards the warehouse where
hadir was taken
but it was there that they were ambushed
by the russian forces
however it was at that very moment when
an sas squad arrived led by a young john
price
before the siblings were evacuated from
the prison farrah introduces herself to
price as commander kareem
the leader of the urzakhstan liberation
front
alex tells farah and her brother hadir
about the stolen gas
they agree to help as long as he will
assist them in the ualif's fight against
the russian forces led by general roman
bakov
alex and farrar go into a nearby city
under disguise
they eventually come across a couple of
helicopters and alex detonates them with
explosives
he brings the russian forces down upon
their position while ferrara keeps them
busy hadir and alex use explosive remote
control planes armed with c4 to take out
several russian vehicles
the ulf forces launch their attack and
are able to capture the armories in the
compound
the russians launch a counter-attack
with heavily armed vehicles
but after a quick call from alex to his
cia contact these were quickly dealt to
by u.s apache attack helicopters
back in england price and garrick leave
an attack on an alcatala safe house
after eliminating the terrorists inside
they find a laptop that provides intel
on the whereabouts of the alcatala
leader known as the wolf
he is hiding out in the hospital in
uzdan
next alex together with a large marine
squad launches an attack on the alcatala
occupied hospital where they would
eventually capture the wolf
they take him to the american embassy
where he would be handed over to price
but the alcatala led by a man called the
butcher arrive demanding the wolf's
release
while all of this is happening the wolf
says that it wasn't them that took the
russian gas though he wishes it was
the butcher attacked the embassy killing
several civilians but price and garrick
have now arrived and managed to help
alex and the wolf escape
their team make their way to a nearby
facility where they take up defensive
positions
they fight their way through to the
ambassador's residence but while they're
fending off the attacks alcatel forces
managed to breach a wall getting away
with their leader
alex farrar and hadir leave the city and
set up a position outside the only
highway out of the city in an attempt to
ambush them
they are able to defeat the enemy but
the wolf hasn't arrived yet
however while waiting they are met by
barkhov's forces
heavily outnumbered hadir grabs alex and
tells him of the explosives in his truck
that they can use
it is here that alex notices the stolen
russian gas in the back of a deer's
truck
padilla puts on the gas mask and carries
both alex and farrar to safety
angry ferrara passes out before she can
do anything hadeer then tells alex that
it's true he did steal the gas
but he had to in order to keep farrar
himself and the ulf in the fight
hadir leaves on foot while alex ii
passes out
price and garrick find alex and ferrar
once they wake up they meet with leswell
hadir in the russian gas has been
tracked to an alcatala stronghold in the
mountains
he has made contact with the wolf and
the butcher to provide them with the gas
to use on bakov's men
garrick and price attack the main
building while farah and alex move
underground into the tunnels where the
wolf is hiding
after fighting through alcatile forces
they eventually find him strapped with
explosives
alex shoots and kills the wolf and
together they disarm the vest
back at hq the team learns that the us
has labeled farrar's organization the
ulf as enemy combatants due to the theft
of russian chemical weapons
alex immediately protests as it has been
ferrara's forces that have been helping
he then goes on to defy the chain of
command leaving with farrar to join her
forces
discussing with leswell price talks of
meeting with a contact called nikolai in
saint petersburg russia
they tracked down the butcher and
managed to take him captive
although he refuses to give any
information he eventually complies after
nikolai appears with the butcher's
family
he tells them of the location of the gas
as well as hadiya's plan of going
directly after barkhov himself
the butcher is left along with the gas
to be collected by the russian army
price and garrick go to barkov's estate
where they find her dear in the office
looking for information around barkhov's
chemical factory
after escaping the compound and
returning to leswell she explains that
they're turning hadir over to the
russians
price agrees it states that he's keeping
the intel on the factory
when price meets up with ferrar she
isn't happy about her brother being
handed over but price offers to destroy
the facility that hedee had provided
information on
assisted by predator drone strikes price
alex garrick and ferrar launch an attack
on barkhov's factory
price and garrick split off to plant
explosive charges while alex and ferrar
fight through to the main building with
the detonator
with the charges ready alex quickly
finds that the detonator has been
damaged during the fighting it would
have to be done manually a suicide
mission
bharat argues that it should be her
doing it but alex convinces her to stay
behind and take care of barkov
after planting the explosives price and
garrick notice barkov's helicopter
flying overhead leaving the compound
fortunately barkov is completely unaware
that farrar has made it on board
finally after 20 years the death of her
parents the prolonged torture of her and
her dear and the invasion of urzakhstan
she is able to take her revenge
after killing barkov she watches out
from the helicopter as the explosions
begin to engulf the facility along with
alex inside
with bakov dead and disowned by russia
price meets with leswell to discuss the
creation of a new task force
although she is initially apprehensive
she ends up accepting an informing price
of a man named zakaiv who is looking to
pick up where bakov lift off
price reveals the names of the people he
wants to recruit
garrick john mctavish simon reilly and a
number of others he chooses to keep to
himself
laswell then asks what are we calling
this new task force
he responds
1 4 1.
following the death of the wolf alcatala
was left without a leader and naturally
there was a power vacuum where a new
leader would eventually emerge posing a
dangerous threat to all russian forces
in verdansk
sergeant kamarov of the federal security
service as well as leswal authorised a
joint operation between the allegiance
and coalition
this new joint faction named armistice
takes on various operations in the dance
including the elimination of several key
figures within the al-kotala terrorist
group
eventually the armistice leadership
would find out that the alcatala has
been dealing an arms trade with zakaiyev
and that the name of the new leader is
khalid al-assad
armistice would continue to send agents
out into the field on missions against
alcatar forces but over time they seem
to be growing levels of hostility
between the two groups that make up the
joint operation
particularly after intercepting an
alcotyler chemical shipment in
urzakhstan
not long after this alcatile unleashes
chemical weapon attacks across verdansk
causing the two factions to fight each
other as well as among themselves for
survival as toxic gas surrounds the city
with all of this happening around him
task force one for one member ghost
request reliable reinforcements of the
comms with price
eventually he would be greeted by
someone who had been presumed dead not
so long ago
alex is back having survived the factory
explosion and he's been sent in to
assist ghost
armistice leaders intercept a phone call
between al-assad and sarkaiv
they learn that alcatala has been
shipping armaments to various bunkers
located throughout vedansk from
experimental weapon prototypes to
nuclear warheads
it has been discovered that zarkai eve
was the one responsible for armistice
being torn apart
from the very beginning he's been paying
off armstead soldiers to turn a blind
eye and even attack other armistice
soldiers
price and garrick were then deployed
into vedansk to assist and with the help
of the private military company called
shadow company they hunt down zarkai
eve's location
they discover that he's been using the
dance subway tunnels to move around
undetected
price sends farah and nikolai to
infiltrate and reclaim the tunnels
restoring power to the metro system
eventually task force one for one hacks
into zarkaev's comms locating him at a
nuclear silo in bunker ten
in the bunker zarkaev has armed the nuke
and is preparing to launch
but suddenly price appears shooting him
and then throwing him over the ledge
down the silo
then with very little time to spare
price manages to terminate the missile
launch with nikolai's help
leaving the facility task force 141 look
out across the region as the battle
continues to play out
when suddenly price is contacted by soap
requesting backup half a kilometer off
the coast
now you might be wondering why i'm
suddenly covering the lore of a game
that is two three years old
one i wanted to cover this at the time
of release but was busy with other
content and two call of duty modern
warfare 2 is coming out in the near
future and from what we can tell so far
it will be a continuation of the 2019
call of duty modern warfare story where
captain price's task force 141 will be
continuing the fight
i'm not going to cover the potential
story direction this next installment
will take in this video but perhaps this
is something i can look into later for
now just look at this as a recap of the
modern warfare story before the sequel
releases
i hope this summary videos help bring
you up to speed i'll likely be covering
a few other aspects of the modern
warfare story in coming videos so if you
have any questions please let me know
otherwise thank you very much for
watching and i'll catch you in the next
one cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]